[Música]
Bienvenidos a reporteros el magazín de
los grandes reportajes de la redacción
de Franz 24 soy herminia Fernández
comenzamos
en Toscana la ciudad costera de rosiñano
parece una postal pero vivía el ritmo de
Las batallas que se libran contra el
gigante belga del sector químico salvai
al principio parecía una buena idea
situar una fábrica de bicarbonato de
sodio cerca de unas canteras de piedra
caliza una de las materias primas para
su fabricación conectado por un
ferrocarril y a orillas del mar para
deshacerse rápidamente de los desechos
generados pero esta situación pronto se
convirtió en una pesadilla para la zona
de producción más importante de Europa
ya en 1999 la Organización de las
Naciones Unidas había declarado que la
fábrica de rosinianos albai era una de
las plantas más contaminantes de Italia
hoy día la ONU todavía se preocupa por
la contaminación en esta ciudad salvaje
acaba de obtener la renovación de su
permiso para arrojar
cincuenta mil toneladas anuales de
desechos al mar durante 12 años se
presentó un recurso de apelación ante el
tribunal administrativo entre tanto la
ciudad permite el acceso a casi todas
sus playas en sueño que cautivan a
turistas del mundo entero
luismanoy Natalia Mendoza y lorenza
pensa nos cuentan más en el siguiente
reportaje
[Música]
sobre más de 4 kilómetros se extiende un
mar azul turquesa
con playas de resplandeciente arena
blanca
Estamos a una centena de kilómetros al
oeste de Florencia en la costa Toscana
de Italia
parece que estuviéramos en las maldivas
o en una playa tropical en esta arena
tan Blanca
un paisaje que no tiene nada de natural
aunque sea poco artificial
si la playa es así de Blanca es por los
desechos de la fábrica de bicarbonato de
sodio
detrás de este cartel el acceso a la
playa Está prohibido la posibilidad de
darse un baño es limitada porque nos
encontramos a orillas de una planta
química que vierte sus desechos
directamente al mar
desde hace 110 años esta fábrica
propiedad de un grupo del sector químico
belga se dedica aquí a fabricar
carbonato bicarbonato de sodio y sodio
cáustico para las Industrias
agroalimentarias farmacéuticas y la
producción de vidrio
en promedio cada año se vierten 146 mil
toneladas de desechos en la playa
incluidos metales pesados según un
informe de Naciones Unidas en la orilla
se han acumulado 500 toneladas de
Mercurio
me subo y después me pasas las cosas
Mario Sabino es un apasionado de la
natación subacuática este instructor de
buceo lamenta la extinción de la fauna y
la flora en esta costa mediterránea
el cuchillo es fundamental porque aquí
no hay mucha visibilidad a veces hay
redes abandonadas es necesario poder
cortarlas y abrirse camino evitando los
peligros
Aunque es un local de la zona no suele
venir por aquí
porque sabe que prácticamente no hay
nada que ver
[Música]
para demostrarlo desciende 10 metros
bajo el agua
no hay signos de vida
en el suelo el paisaje está desierto
[Música]
todo está cubierto por una capa blanca
de sedimentos
[Música]
le sorprende la ausencia de un elemento
en particular
vuelvo a subir por aquí
una alga que crece cerca de las costas
porque necesita luz
una zona por la transparencia del agua
que está alterada en esta zona el ciclo
reproductivo de la posidonia quedó
totalmente perjudicado
además los sedimentos que se vierten en
el mar se acumulan en el fondo y hacen
que todo se sofoquen
los fondos marinos de los alrededores
cuando las corrientes no arrastran los
desechos de la fábrica
para ver flora y fauna sanas
características del Mediterráneo hay que
desplazarse al menos cinco kilómetros y
medio de la zona de desechos
alejarse bastante de la fábrica
esta planta típica de la Cuenca
mediterránea tiene un papel muy
importante sirve de refugio para la
reproducción de una gran cantidad de
especies
Las observaciones de este apasionado del
buceo Fueron confirmadas por la agencia
Regional de protección del medio
ambiente en uno de sus informes afirman
lo siguiente
la pradera de posidonias frente a
rosinianos sufrió una regresión hacia el
Tamara
la fábrica de rosiñano ha tenido un
serio impacto ambiental
durante mucho tiempo llamada mama solvay
la planta química ha empleado a miles de
personas enrosiniano
la ciudad de 16.000 habitantes se
estructuró alrededor de su desarrollo
hasta el punto de adoptar su nombre aquí
el gigante del sector químico belga está
en todas partes en las calles en las
fachadas de las escuelas en el estadio
municipal y hasta en el centro cultural
hoy varios habitantes se reúnen para un
evento especial hasta el alcalde de la
ciudad participa en la promoción de la
actividad de la empresa de manera
excepcional solvay abre sus puertas
aprovechamos la ocasión para visitar las
instalaciones normalmente cerradas al
público
[Música]
los empleados se movilizaron para hacer
pedagogía y tranquilizar a la población
solo son sólidos inertes naturales que
se derivan de un proceso hecho a partir
de materias primas que son a su vez
transformadas en polvo en la práctica
son inertes
actualmente la planta emplea a 1600
personas
es dirigida por Nicolás duyante que
lleva 20 años de carrera en la empresa
aunque no suele dar entrevistas pudimos
hablar con él y le preguntamos por la
composición exacta de los desechos que
se acumulan en la costa desde hace más
de un siglo
son sólidos que están autorizados
inertes sin embargo varios estudios
señalan la presencia de metales pesados
que los pescados de los alrededores
absorben
si están de acuerdo en la entrevista de
hoy hablaremos sobre temas relacionados
con la jornada de puertas abiertas si
tienen preguntas técnicas específicas
sobre un documento que no he leído
previamente Les propongo que lo envíen
directamente al servicio de
Comunicaciones y le daremos una
respuesta
la empresa nos remitió a su página de
internet afirma que respetan todos los
estándares italianos y europeos y que
cumplen con todos los controles
sin embargo la planta ha sido acusada
más de una vez por la fiscalía de
liborno y asociaciones de protección del
medio ambiente en dos ocasiones averías
en el funcionamiento generaron una
dispersión de nitrato de amoniaco
devastando la fauna de los alrededores
unas acusaciones que el grupo belga
todavía desmiente
y esta no es la única contaminación que
preocupa a los locales
Maximiliano posareli conoce bien la
fábrica de rosillano vive a una centena
de metros de la planta
[Música]
desde aquí se ve la zona de fabricación
del sodio lo que yo veo
cosavedo veo la muerte dedo
su padre Romano posareli trabajó en la
fábrica la mayor parte de su vida
profesional murió de un cáncer
fulminante en 2010
[Música]
voy caminando
los primeros síntomas fueron su
dificultad para respirar y para moverse
[Música]
nos dijeron que tenía un tumor en los
pulmones y que era por el cigarrillo yo
no les creí porque nunca vi a mi padre
fumar entonces investigué por mi cuenta
Maximiliano no tenía dudas su padre
había estado expuesto a las vesto
durante años
esa habría sido la causa de su cáncer de
pleura
en este documento están todas las tareas
que hizo mi padre en la fábrica
en fondo y sin embargo al final está
escrito que mi padre nunca estuvo en
contacto con el asbesto
Maximiliano demostró lo contrario al
cabo de diez años de proceso judicial en
junio de 2021 el tribunal de liborno
sentenció que solvay debía pagar una
indemnización la empresa negó su
responsabilidad y apeló el fallo
el caso de su padre no sería el único
Maximiliano nos mostró este documento
donde aparecen todas las patologías que
los empleados de la empresa han
desarrollado es un resultado de sus
investigaciones
Esta es la lista desafortunadamente es
larga
cada diagnóstico corresponde a un
empleado
por ejemplo este murió de un tumor en la
pleura
trabajaba en el área de plomería como mi
padre
la prevalencia de cánceres de pleura en
rosillano es tres veces superior a la de
otras ciudades de Toscana una enfermedad
ligada asbesto que se manifiesta años
después de la exposición al mineral
solvay asegura que ya no hayas visto en
el complejo de rosillano pero el
problema de salud pública va más allá un
médico se dedicó a estudiar las causas
de fallecimiento en la ciudad
el doctor Claudio marabotti es
cardiólogo
llevó a cabo un estudio estadístico
durante 10 años comparando la cantidad y
las causas de fallecimiento en rosellano
con el resto de la región a través de
este análisis estadístico se comprobó
que efectivamente aquí existen
enfermedades por las que las personas
mueren más que el resto de Toscana de
manera más significativa
estadísticamente
en promedio cada mes aquí se producen
dos muertes más que en cualquier otra
zona de Toscana cánceres de pleura
enfermedades cardíacas Y
neurodegenerativas son las más
frecuentes
los metales pesados entran en la cadena
alimenticia algunos se acumulan en el
organismo por ejemplo El mercurio entra
pero nunca vuelve a salir Entonces
aunque se ingieran cantidades muy
pequeñas que podrían parecer inofensivas
pero que se ingieren todos los días eso
tiene consecuencias biológicas al cabo
de los años El mercurio puede causar
enfermedades neurodegenerativas como el
alzheimer
desde hace tres años el doctor Claudio
marabotti está solicitando un estudio
más profundo para cruzar los datos sobre
las emisiones contaminantes en la ciudad
con el desarrollo de las enfermedades
ya en 1999 la Organización de las
Naciones Unidas había declarado que la
fábrica de rosillanos solvay era una de
las plantas más contaminantes de Italia
hoy en día la ONU todavía se preocupa
por la contaminación en esta ciudad
invito al gobierno italiano asegurarse
que la industria esté utilizando
tecnologías y métodos de producción que
no afecten la salud de los ciudadanos a
que desarrolle una estrategia para
gestionar los desechos y que establezca
una economía circular Empezando por la
reducción de los desechos en un informe
presentado durante la sesión celebrada
el pasado mes de septiembre en Ginebra
el relator especial sobre los derechos
humanos y el medio ambiente señaló el
riesgo de Green washing es decir el
peligro de compromisos ecológicos
superficiales sin efectos reales los
desechos que la empresa llama sólidos
inertes
contiene mercurio y otros metales
pesados que se encuentran en la costa de
Toscana
esa es la razón que explica el color de
las playas alrededor de rosigniano y es
un asunto preocupante
acaba de obtener la renovación de su
permiso para arrojar hasta 250.000
toneladas anuales de desechos al mar
durante 12 años se presentó un recurso
de apelación ante el tribunal
administrativo ante la presión la
empresa anunció que contemplaría el cese
de esta actividad para el año 2050
entre tanto la ciudad permite el acceso
a casi todas sus playas de ensueño que
cautivan a turistas del mundo entero
hasta aquí reporteros de la semana
Recuerda que para sintonizar esta y las
emisiones anteriores puede visitar
nuestro sitio web France 24.com hasta la
próxima
[Música]